look at that little cutie she's amazing
he's a happy baby Rihanna shares a video
of her and ASAP Rocky's adorable son for
the first time and boy he's got
personality
it's amazing and I'm honestly truly
blessed for real you know on Saturday
the proud mama shared this short clip of
her son on Tick Tock the baby boy whose
name has not been revealed yet is
sitting in his car seat enjoying some
quality time with reread
I'm trying to get mommy fun
oh wow oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
so cute check out Reece showing off his
hands as he tries to take the phone away
from her once again
[Music]
it's all an exciting Journey so far I'm
just taking it as it comes every week
it's something new and I'm just taking
it Rihanna and ASAP Rocky welcomed their
first child their baby boy into the
world last May and last month A source
told ET that Riri has more babies on the
brain saying in part quote Rihanna has
always dreamed of being a mom and she
takes a lot of pride in it she would
love to have more children with ASAP in
the future what are you enjoying about
this journey with three right now
everything about it I'm loving it
Rihanna recently revealed to E.T the one
thing that makes her heart sing when it
comes to Motherhood oh my God the
morning's just like seeing his morning
face yeah and you know like seeing a
baby with like little bags and waking up
and they're just like startled they're
trying to figure out where they at is
the cutest it's my favorite part of the
day as the star enjoys mom life she also
has a number of things on her plate
including headlining the 2023 Super Bowl
halftime show it's nerve-wracking you
want to get it right you know
everybody's watching
and they're rooting for you yeah and I
want I want to get it right so one of
the challenge that I was willing to
accept well being a new mom nothing
would have gotten me out the house if it
wasn't a challenge like that well
another challenge that Rihanna might
take on designing baby clothes Yep looks
like the style icon is taking
inspiration from this little cutie you
know I always thought doing kid stuff
would be like
cliche and obviously the the obvious
thing to do when you have nothing cliche
when you have a baby right it's like the
obvious Next Step but when I went
shopping
um
that's what I realized like okay maybe I
need to start making the stuff that I
want my kids to wear because it's hard
it's hard I got my own like idea like
what give it to me tell me your vision
board she is about to just put it all
out I'm gonna give you my ideas girl
[Music]